what up space fam goes in here for anime
out bro and I'm back at it again to talk
about the latest crazy updates to the
demon Slayers story I did not see the
twist that happened at the end coming
and it could be the most tragic one yet
so make sure to stay tuned for that if
you enjoy seeing these Demon Slayer
videos on the channel make sure to smash
that like button to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell because you
will miss new Demon Slayer videos if you
don't for more demons air content and
crucial updates about the new anime
movie and seasons
make sure to follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar a quick
warning there will be manga spoilers in
this video we're going to be talking
about the latest chapter chapter 100 84
after all you've been warned now without
further ado let's jump into it if you
recall in the last chapter the demon
Slayers succeeded in getting moves on
above-ground in large part thanks to you
shoot oh it's still night time but at
least there's hope now if they can stall
moves on for long enough the Sun could
potentially kill him
when tangelo comes to he notices that
they aren't just anywhere they're in the
city where Mouzon could potentially do a
lot of damage if innocent civilians
start getting caught up in the mix that
would be a big problem and put the demon
Slayers at a significant disadvantage we
jump to Commander kiria the HQ team is
concerned about how moves on and Adiemus
errors are significantly far from the
expected destination no one probably
expected for them to come out in a city
and despite what I thought was gonna
happen last chapter we have yet to see
the reunion of the demon Slayers it
seems like they didn't all come to the
same place at the same time so we have
to wait longer for demon slayer Goku aka
Yomi to make it to the scene
nevertheless Kia is impressed and in a
skills showdown between ushido and moves
on you should have succeeded in bringing
moves on to the surface
he thinks that what you should
accomplish is nothing short of amazing
again props to you Shiro who turned out
to be a total boss and way more useful
than I expected him to be at first Kyoya
asks one of his sisters how long it will
take until sunrise she is clearly
panicked and with beads of sweat all
over her face she comments that there is
still an hour and a half
on hearing this kiria who is similarly
sweating looks extremely panicked
after all that is a long time against
the demon king of pop not only do the
demon Slayers have to try and survive
long enough they also can't let moves on
escape and in a city he's going to have
much more opportunities to escape if he
decides to he should be the fastest and
strongest as well so we have to hold
that pure pride keeps him from running
away to fight another night he did
mention that his goal was to kill the
demon Slayers tonight so he has
motivation to stay until he accomplishes
that a crow passes on the message that
there's still an hour and a half until
sunrise tundra can't help but think that
this is too much time as he's looking
for everyone he sees that me to the
eager Ong you are safe eager Ong you
seem calm as usual but in contrast to
that me truly is providing some comedic
relief again her eyes are popping out if
she cries sweats and shakes if anything
this makes me respect the calm composure
of eager oh and give you all the more
time Jiro himself is not so calm he's
trying to sniff out moves on his injured
eye is still bleeding and he's sweating
all over trying to maintain his
breathing then all of a sudden moves on
pops up from under a bunch of debris he
casts everything aside like it's nothing
in the last video I talked about how
Mulan would have to show any cards he
has up his sleeve soon and that that
could be another form and at this point
we see that Mouzon has in fact adopted a
different looking more powerful form he
now has what appears to be 10 whips
coming from his back and they all have
sharp blades at the end of them now it
really seems like no one else is going
to be able to get close to them even
before ton zero couldn't dodge him when
he was fighting with two limbs and now
he has at least ten more to fight with
Mouzon asks if they actually intend to
keep him here until sunrise he invites
them to try if they can showing that he
is down to fight at least for a time
instead of just running away and
continuing to fight another night the
amount of devastation this guy can cause
by just swinging around his limbs is
absolutely crazy but I guess that's to
be expected from the main antagonist at
least he can't destroy the entire planet
with a laser beam like Frieza the three
pillars do their best to dodge and then
close in for the combined attack my boy
agudo actually succeeds in cutting
through Milan's neck we
knew that you can't kill Mouzon by
cutting off his neck but we at least
expect that such an attack to slow them
down a bit however that's not the case
at all literally as the sword is passing
through the neck the neck is already
healing
as soon as the section of the neck gets
cut it immediately heals so you can't
realistically even hope to detach
Mullins head unless Guillaume a comes in
with his wrecking ball as far as swords
go though it seems like they don't
weaken moves on a single bit I am
wondering what would happen if one of
those red tinge blades cut moves on
I'm guessing such an attack would have
to be more effective it should at least
take him longer to recover we get a
scene of how all the pillars are
attacking moves on at once and it looks
pretty awesome we see that give sword is
broken and we see meat so these really
cool blade bending around moves on
however they just can't do any damage to
moves on and not surprisingly meat city
is worried and wonders if they even cut
him view points out that they did but
moves on is such a monster he
regenerates the moment he's cut then the
pillars realized they're dangerously
close to moves on and open to attack
just as mutually is about to get hit a
lower-ranking demon slayer takes the hit
for her some demon Slayers take the hits
for ego role and give you a shock to see
this after all pillars are supposed to
protect the rest that's how it usually
goes here my long-standing question is
finally answered I've been wondering for
a while what purpose these weaker demon
Slayers would serve i knew that they'd
just be easily killed by Mouzon but it
seems like that is part of their purpose
their purpose is to become human shields
for the pillars so that the pillars can
fight longer these guys bravely protect
the pillars by sacrificing their own
lives
it's like sacrificing pawns in a game of
chess to protect your rooks
it does actually give the demon slayers
a better chance of winning despite how
much weaker these guys are they did turn
out to be useful and you have to respect
their courage and honor it goes to show
that even the weakest characters can
make a significant difference after all
it these three pillars were to die the
chances of beating and moves on would
fall dramatically
I sometimes comment on how much I like
the fact that beating an Opie demon
almost always includes teamwork in demon
slayer rather than Frieza killing a
bunch of people in Goku becoming a Super
Saiyan overpowering him
handedly we have fights where seemingly
weaker characters like Kenya and Yoshino
end up playing instrumental roles in the
demon battles but this chapter takes it
to a whole other level all these
characters are way weaker than Kenya and
you [ __ ] off and they just played a
vital role in the battle by saving the
pillars the mangakas message seems to be
clear no matter how talented you are you
can always make a difference if you can
just muster up the courage to do the
right thing I'm truly touched by the
sacrifice of these guys and I don't
think we should skim past this part
without appreciating how much guts it
took for them to do this they are all
heroes without a doubt even punch our
main character is saved because one of
the lower demon Slayers saved him by
sacrificing his own life tonzura will no
doubt be one of the most important
characters in defeating moves on that's
how shown at work and he could have just
died if not for this brave faceless
demon slayer who saved him the lower
demon slayers say that the pillars saved
their lives countless times they
wouldn't even be alive if it wasn't for
the pillars so in a way this is their
way of paying them back one of them says
don't be afraid of fighting as they keep
getting killed Mitsui tells them to stop
what time zero seems to hold out hope
for victory
if Tonto and the pillars followed the
lower demon slayers
then maybe they can overcome Mouzon
somehow Tonto doesn't want their
sacrifices to be for nothing
he's running but suddenly tons of Falls
and starts coughing out blood Mouzon
says that those who die quickly are the
fortunate ones he says even if they
don't die right away those who attack
him are done for he tells everyone to
look in contras direction they're
shocked to see Tonto on the ground he is
screaming and his left eye wound is
spreading across his face Mouzon
explains that tons of soaked up muslims
blood during his attack the amount of
blood was too much he says it won't turn
him into a demon but like poison it will
destroy his cells until he dies Tundra
looks absolutely terrible in the last
panel and Mulan says that Tantra is
already dead this is absolutely
unbelievable this is by far the craziest
twist we've seen in demon slayer so far
ton zero our main protagonist has been
pronounced as good as dead now do we
believe that Tantra our main character
will die I don't see that happening so
most likely one of the
Amazon said is already wrong this leads
me to believe that potentially Tantra
could become a demon this would be the
craziest twist ever but I think it's
possible Nez Zuko is a demon and she can
still fight against booze on the same
should be possible for ton judo
if he becomes a demon you should be able
to regenerate his eye and recover from
his life-threatening injuries throughout
the series we've already established
that there are good demons and bad
demons and the good demons like mezu
Kota Mayo and you should all have played
vital roles in fighting against moons on
I'm not at all saying that this will
happen for sure but I think that Tantra
becoming a demon is possible and
furthermore then he'll unlock some new
powers via blood demon arts and he'll
still be able to practice breathing like
Kakashi bo eventually along with nez
Zuko he could potentially be cured to
let me know what you think about this
possible theory how do you think tundra
is going to get out of this one I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the craziest
Demon Slayer chapter yet thank you for
watching if you enjoyed this one I would
especially appreciate if you could leave
a like and share this video with a
fellow Dimas air fan if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is extremely
important hit that notification bell so
you actually know when new Dimas error
videos come out and remember if you want
more Dimas air content and crucial
updates about the new movie and seasons
you can follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar a big thank
you goes out to our patrons over on
patreon who help make videos like this
one possible I'm blown away by the
amount of patience we have and I'm
extremely thankful to each and every one
of you I especially want to thank our
pro hero to your patrons the one and
only Gilgamesh baby ray nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson Kings I'll just $30
bathe at Karachi and Anatoly Cassatt's
key DJ Nathaniel alpha deal and angel
Cruz and are the one tier patrons the
ones who stay atop all clans Stephen and
Radha al-hola naught I'm Matty Mac 239
makoto-kun Seth Cooper and the world if
you enjoy our work you can support more
of it by going over to patreon calm an
amine or and becoming a patron today for
as little as $1 if you do so you'll get
your name featured in future videos
alongside these um
easing people right here and you'll even
get access for private patron only
discord so check out patreon calm and
make in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits thanks for
everything and until next time see you
space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]